uh we're very excited to have uh lilian
ratliff from the university of
washington
uh he really works on a bunch of like
really exciting problems on like
learning games differential games
control theories and so forth
and uh today she'll be talking about
talking with us about uh beyond open and
loop algorithm design
thanks so much and the flow is yours all
right thanks georgios
yeah so i want to talk a little bit uh
first of all this is the first time i'm
giving a talk in person in like two and
a half years so i apologize if it's a
little awkward i might find myself
because normally you're like staring at
your computer so yeah so if you have
questions and i don't notice just yell
out
yeah so i want to talk about some of the
work that we have going on in my group
on thinking about how to
close the loop in machine learning and
so in particular focused on learning
from decision dependent data and that's
suggested sort of by the the name of the
workshop we're often thinking about um
you know data that's generated by
strategic data sources
so we'll start first with sort of the
traditional perspective
so if you're thinking about designing a
prediction or classification algorithm
or maybe more generally some decision
making algorithm
sort of the typical way that this is
done is that we uh assume that we have
some training data let's say
that's representative of
you know the the environment or the
problem that we're going to try to
learn about uh and then we design our
algorithm and we deploy it in the real
world
um and so we sort of kind of believe
that the training data is not going to
really depend on the the decision of the
algorithm so it's sort of both
representative of the past and the
future
so what i'll argue is that in a lot of
uh
modern systems this kind of perspective
needs to be revised uh or doesn't really
work leads to unintended consequences
and i'll give some examples here in a
minute but this is sort of spurred on by
the fact that we now have
you know
human decision makers that have edge
devices and they're able to react in
real time for example
two decisions that are being made
whether that's in the context of any one
of these applications shown here or
various others
so let me give some examples of how
things can fail if you stick with this
sort of open loop point of view
so start with an example of failures
that result from
traditionally designing these algorithms
without thinking about the fact that the
algorithm might change the underlying
data distribution
so
this is an example of uh feedback
reinforced bias so not just bias in the
data but also institutional bias
related to predictive policing so
there's um many companies that uh you
know provide these predictive policing
algorithms one is this uh company pred
poll and so this is a study um that was
reported in this royal statistical
society in 2016. basically what you're
seeing here on the
the
your right your left hand side i guess
um is uh on the top this is drug arrest
in 2010 in the east bay area so this is
you know we're up here in berkeley and
this is like the oakland area and you
can see kind of in downtown oakland
there's a concentrated spot of drug
arrest and then sort of there's some
along this corridor into fremont
um then the bottom you're seeing
estimated drug use from a 2011 national
survey
and you know these red the red is the
actual drug use or whatever and like
it's widespread so it's not concentrated
in particular in those areas nonetheless
when
uh you use pred poll to predict uh day
ahead hot spots where you know this
gives suggestions to police of where
they can go to sort of look for uh do
their patrol to look for illicit uh drug
use it keeps predicting in the same you
know downtown area that isn't really
representative of where drug use is
moreover at least you know in 2010
demographics may have changed this is an
area that has uh you know a larger
percentage of persons of color living in
that
vicinity and if you look over here on
the right you can kind of see
basically police targeting for illicit
drug use by race
is concentrated in the persons of color
community while actual estimated drug
use by race tells an opposite story
and so
that was 2016. you know now we're in
2022 and last year at the very end of
last year there was
a leak of data from an unsecured pred
poll server
that um
these authors who posted this on gizmodo
basically showed that the problem is
widespread and continuing to exist so
these are all
the red locations are using pred poll
and the black locations use some other
predictive policing algorithm so pred
poll has a new name by the way it's
called geoanalytic or geolytica now
and you can see basically
the
result of this actual data is showing
that again
it's targeting communities of color and
they also have some plots showing it
targeting
lower income communities as well so we
recognize there's a problem five years
ago and we still haven't really done
anything to fix it
a second sort of set of problems that
are
you know rising in the space is that
oftentimes uh these algorithms are being
trained
without uh considering that the data is
generated by human users so that of
course is one of the motivations i guess
of this workshop
and so as another example
this is uh
you know in 2019 it was reported that
uber and lyft drivers were colluding
together to
cause a trigger in surge pricing so
basically at locations like
airports where they have these
uh you know
areas where drivers can
they congregate before they pick
passengers up all of these drivers would
get together and say okay i'm going to
turn my phone off so they would all turn
their phone off they cause a dip in
supply this triggers the surge mechanism
to kick in and then they turn their
phones on and capitalize on that and the
problem is this leads to negative
externalities because the cost gets
offloaded onto the passenger side of the
market
so the design of these algorithms wasn't
really thinking about for doing say
surge pricing for example or predicting
demand that leads to a decision about
surge pricing
they're not really thinking about
these sort of
unintended behaviors and it's difficult
because at these locations like airports
oftentimes this kind of behavior is hard
to detect because there's already
volatility in the demand and supply
okay so in both of these examples we
have the situation where we're sort of
ignoring uh the feedback loop
um in uh
in the design of the algorithm so we
want to start moving towards a set of
algorithms that can account for this
this kind of behavior so over here on
the on the sort of set up the problem
space
over here on your left we're seeing sort
of this open loop uh problems where you
want to solve some expected uh let's say
loss minimization problem or risk
minimization problem you can also do
this in the context of empirical risk
minimization but i'll just talk about
the expected loss case
we want to move towards considering
a decision dependent distribution so
this looks like a simple change
but really it's not and the challenge is
that this distribution is typically a
priori unknown and the reason is that
it's generated for example by strategic
users whose preferences aren't known a
priori and so this really is
representative of some information
asymmetries between this
decision-dependent learner is trying to
solve this problem and the environment
where you have this sort of reaction to
the decision
so we'll just come back i'm going to
keep coming back to this ride share
example because it's simple and kind of
easy to communicate about and i have
some simulations at the end to
illustrate some interesting directions
for
future research so if you think about
this problem of say predicting demand
based on surge and let's say supply so
let's say you're one of these platforms
and you want to you know take a bunch of
supply data and maybe some other
features
and learn
a prediction algorithm for demand and
then you might use this for various
things one thing you might use it for is
to create this heat map which both uber
and lyft do
that presents information to drivers so
they can then react in some way so now
you have you know your supplies the
drivers sort of reacting to this
information that's shown on that heat
map
and that kind of behavior can either be
strategic behavior so they're just
planning you know their day like where
am i going to go
to maximize my individual
revenue or it could be adversarial like
this collusion example
and so the work that we're doing
in my group and several others of course
are working in this space as well we've
been thinking about both these problems
of adversarial behavior as well as
strategic
uh you know strategically generated data
but also thinking about situations where
you have dynamics so for example in many
behavioral models
in particular if we're talking about
humans it takes time for them to react
to announced mechanisms so this is
pretty typical in say prospect theory
and various other behavioral models
where humans compare to reference points
so they have some history so we want to
account for that sort of delay so we
have a little bit of work in that space
and then we also care about this setting
where we have competition so of course
rideshare is a good example of that you
have say multiple platforms that are
engaging with the same population of
drivers and the same population of
writers
so across all of these kind of areas the
sort of key insight is that we can sort
of revisit these learning and decision
making problems
using game theoretic abstractions
and so for the rest of the talk i'll
just focus on this one particular
area so thinking about what happens when
you have competition between
decision dependent learners
okay
so i'll just
motivate this again with a few other
examples beyond the rideshare case so in
many real world settings you have
algorithms that are interacting so you
can think about
for instance
these mapping applications so it might
be waze google apple maps they're all
giving routing suggestions to different
users who are then executing them in the
same physical
environment and then each of these
routing applications in turn is
observing that behavior and making
decisions so there's interaction between
the decisions
of the the different mapping
applications and how it impacts the
decisions of the users
similarly
in
you know whether we're talking about
university admissions or loan
procurement you might have multiple
institutions that have different desert
errata
and then you have applicants that are
trying to get positively classified by
one or more of these institutions and so
they might adjust their sort of
application
in response to the desiderata of these
different institutions
so i want to kind of
before getting into the details of
things i want to just give a little bit
of uh history on this kind of problem
space
and so
in the open loop setting we're talking
about say
traditional risk minimization and
machine learning
and so then
uh we can start to think a little bit
about this closed-loop setting where we
have this decision dependence and so
this problem it has its sort of roots in
stochastic programming and control i
mean this looks sort of naturally like a
uh either a static reinforcement
learning problem or a control problem
so there's a nice review paper from 2018
covering uh you know work going back to
the 80s
and the predominant focus here was
problems and operations research related
to resource allocation
and so for the most part the work
doesn't really think about strategic
behavior or the fact that this
distribution is somehow unknown and a
result of strategic behavior
on the other hand in the machine
learning optimization community very
recently there's been
several
different lines of work so the first i
would say started with thinking about
strategic classification there's various
formulations for strategic
classification
there are several
focusing on the optimization point of
view that are relevant to the to what
i'll talk about today and sort of a
blanket problem for that is what's
called performative prediction uh and so
there's several lines of work on that
mostly coming out of berkeley
so that's already a hard problem so just
to reiterate why this is a hard problem
if you think about even optimizing
this sort of closed loop learning
problem if you will we can start with
first order conditions and you can see
there's this
if we break up the the gradient
we have this explicit partial gradient
and this guy can be computed pretty
easily
with samples so all we're doing is
taking the gradient of our loss function
with it
with respect to the x
uh dependence in the loss so explicit
dependence and loss and not yet with
respect to the decision dependence so
fairly easy to compute without knowledge
of this
data distribution on the other hand if
we
look at the second term here
this is a implicit what i'll call
implicit partial gradient and so it's
the gradient uh of uh you know this
expected loss given that we have this
decision dependent uh data distribution
so this is not computable without some a
priori knowledge of this data
distribution which is what makes this
problem difficult
so then what we're going to do is layer
on top of it an additional set of
difficulties so we're going to
study the problem where you have
multiple of these decision makers
and we have explicit
competition meaning that the loss for
each player depends not on not only on
their own actions but the actions of
others
and then in addition their data
distribution will depend on again their
actions and the actions of others and so
several people have been formulating
this problem including uh georgos and
then there's a and his uh collaborators
and there's a group at uh
uc boulder who's also been working on
the space
um and i'll give credit to uh
adian and evan who are my students who
came up with this problem
uh as a course project an audience here
if you would like to talk to him he's
sitting in the back and um
so they came up with this idea to look
at this problem uh and so we've been
working on it over the last year so
so again i'll come back to this silly
little example um
so
we have our ride share set up and so
let's say uber is this main guy here
who's trying to make a prediction of
demand but now we have lyft coming into
play and they're also you know showing
drivers information and passengers
information and these guys are sort of
comparing you know where can they make
the most money or which is going to be
the cheaper ride so as a result the data
distribution of whatever learning
problem in this case let's say
predicting demand
is going to be a function of both
platforms actions
so we want to capture that
so what i'll do in the rest of the talk
is
describe
two sort of settings so one is the naive
setting
so that's where players just say okay
this is too difficult to deal with so
i'm going to kind of ignore that
implicit partial gradient component
or the explicit sort of competition
that's showing up here and we're going
to do repeated retraining and so
for that case we're going to come up
with
relevant equilibrium concepts
including existence in uniqueness and
then algorithms to compute those
equilibrium concepts
then we'll switch gears to where players
have some level of uh you know they're
not as myopic and so they come up with
some a way to estimate the effect of
this
uh decision dependence in the data
distribution and again we'll do the same
sort of setup
say when equilibria exist when they're
unique and come up with algorithms to
find those equilibrium and then i'll
conclude with some little toy uh so what
we call semi-synthetic
experiments in this space so i'll have
use some real data to illustrate sort of
the the interaction or the sort of
compare these different equilibrium
concepts
okay let's start with a naive case
and let's suppose players are going to
do
repeated retraining in a naive way
okay so
what is repeated retraining
and what is sort of the the natural
solution concept that it converges to so
we'll start with a solution concept so
we can think about the single player
setting um and so
uh i think this initially was uh defined
in the paper by perdomo at all
they call this solution here so there's
no there's just one player and they want
to solve this risk minimization problem
let's say
and so
if they ignore the decision dependence
then we can define what's called a
proformally stable point so you kind of
fix your distribution at this x s
and then the solution of this our our
minimization problem should also be
excess and that's a performantly stable
point so we can extend this to the
multiplayer setting
and the natural way to do that is to
find an auxiliary game
and so this game
is a game just in the explicit
dependence in the loss
on uh you know with respect to x i and x
minus i but it's induced by the the
this uh
y variable here so this joint um
so y here is a an element of the joint
action space so that shows up in the
decision dependent distribution
so given that auxiliary gain we can
define a performance performably stable
equilibrium and i put equilibrium in
quotes here on purpose because it's not
an equilibrium sort of in a game
theoretic sense but more
in
the sense of it arises as a result of
the
repeated uh
retraining that i'll show on the next
slide
and so essentially we want it to be a
point
that um is a for each player is an
argument of this optimization problem
where sort of importantly we have
xs in the decision dependent
distribution here and then x minus s
in the loss
okay yeah i guess before getting into
the definition of this repeated
retraining
we're going to set up some assumptions
that we'll need throughout
so we have
sort of the
the sort of typical things here for our
joint action space it's going to be
convex compact these are going to these
conditions are going to be needed to get
existence
and then we're going to assume that our
this
auxiliary game here so for any y any
joint action y
the auxiliary game
induced by that y
is alpha strongly monotone and so i put
the definition here of strong
monotonicity for a game just as a way to
to remind folks but essentially it means
that
for some game
defined by these cost functions f here
if we look at the vector of individual
gradients we want that guy to be that
mapping to be a strongly monotone
mapping which just means uh you know
this inequality here holds
so what does it mean for this game to be
strongly monitored or one way to start
to think about what this means and how
restrictive it is if we think about the
case of separable losses so let's
suppose this loss here doesn't depend on
x minus i
so we still have the the competition
through this decision dependent
distribution
in that case then all this assumption
too means is that
the losses are going to be
strongly convex in the choice variable
of the agent so that's sort of what this
boils down to if we remove that explicit
dependence on x minus i
okay so then we're also going to need
some regularity conditions uh on our
losses so they need to be sufficiently
smooth
and we need
some uh
you know smoothness condition on the
partial gradient uh
of the loss with respect to x i
we also need some growth conditions uh
on our
uh irregularity conditions on our
decision dependent distribution so this
is the wasserstein one distance here
between the two distributions induced by
x and y and we need that to have uh you
know satisfy this inequality
okay
so these are the sort of assumptions
we're going to make
and then what we're going to do is
define this quantity rho down here
which just has these sort of regularity
constants showing up here in the
numerator and then the strong
monotonicity parameter in the
denominator so this guy's going to be
fundamentally important for ensuring
that our algorithms actually converge
and that we have existence of equilibria
okay so
you see i thought that the model has
only the x and the excitement you
remind again because it's the first time
that i saw the mother what is the g
i mean what is the game where the game
is playing the role what is it
uh let me just go back here
so the
each player is choosing uh so player i
is choosing xi
and their distribution the data
distribution depends on
x i and and the decisions of all the
other players x minus sign and similarly
their loss also depends on x i and x
minus that
okay and then where is the game and
operator
the model operator that you refer
oh uh so
maybe i don't know what you're asking uh
yeah so you're asking
uh
yeah what are you asking exactly
what is that z of y oh it's this
it's the auxiliary game induced by y so
y shows up down here and then we have a
game still in terms of the explicit
dependence in the loss function oh
okay
so there's still a game even if we fix y
here there's still a game between the
players
any joint action in the joint action
space of all the players
so we can define a game for any y we can
define this auxiliary game
this is fixed but we still have the
dependence on x i and x minus i here
so this is because maybe it'll make
sense once i define repeated routine
so what repeated retraining is in a
single player case you also sort of fix
the distribution at the previous action
x t
and then you just optimize with respect
to the explicit dependence in the loss
function
and for the game case we'll do the same
thing we're going to define this induced
game by the previous action
so that's xt here in the data
distribution and then we still have a
game between the players in terms of
x i
and so because we're defining nash here
this is y minus i
so we want to
for the repeated retraining case in the
multiplier case we're going to compute a
nash equilibrium of the game induced by
the previous action xt
this makes sense
okay
all right so then
uh when we have now that we have this
repeated retraining process
um
we can
figure out when performatively stable
points exist and then show when repeated
retraining converges simply with a sort
of fixed point argument and so in order
to make sure that this thing is a
contraction this process that we're
repeating on we need a row here to be
less than one so then simultaneously
this sort of gives us
existence
and in fact uniqueness because of the
nice conditions we've assumed on our
cost functions and things
as well as convergence of this process
um so yeah this is the when row is less
than one is the interesting regime here
because in terms of the problem
parameters because this gives us
the setting in which we
have an equilibrium that exists
another interesting thing to point out
if we look at the separable case
so again this just means that
the loss function in this let's go back
to this
so in this case here
if
uh
in the separable case there's no
dependence anymore
explicit dependence in the loss function
on the actions of others so then it's
just for each player it's simply an
optimization problem
and so in that case
um
the only competition is occurring from
the previous iteration so in the
decision dependent distribution
and so in that setting we end up getting
uh the interesting regime being the
setting where rho squared can be less
than one and that gives us an improved
rate in terms of square root row
and i guess the important thing to
mention here is that it matches the
single player setting so in the single
player setting there's no competition at
all and so if you are actually to uh
write down convergence guarantees and
existence guarantees
for these performantly stable points
then you'd find that um you know the
parameter that shows up here is in fact
square root rho
to be clear under your assumptions this
dash operator is
yeah informative prediction usually
there is a performative stability and
performative optimality yeah
the notion of the automatic optimality
that'll be the same i'm getting to that
after i finish this repeated stuff we'll
talk about nash nash is the sort of
natural generalization generalization of
performance of optimality
okay well there's two sort of
generalizations if you care about
you know the social optimum or something
like that you feel completely
competitive or cooperative so no
competition everybody's like optimizing
the joint for the sum of losses
then uh maybe the natural generalization
would be the social optimum but if it's
competitive the natural generalization
is a nash eq
but i missed it how exactly do you
calculate the equilibrium g of x t
you need the mass of g of x theta right
of g of x sorry
how do you calculate that
um so
i'll give it i'll talk about that in
just a second okay
hey just understand something
that it is written the operator is
trying to put a generalized agreement in
a concave game
here let me talk about how we can
actually compute this
so uh one way to compute this uh guy
it's not even i mean so
um
we're not even any so as we run this
algorithm we're not going to compute the
nash equilibrium of
you know a bunch of iterates uh sorry
we're not going to compute
the nash at each instance induced by xt
instead what we're going to do is run
this repeated stochastic gradient plate
and this will converge to this the
performatively stable point
so in each step players just do a like a
myopic
update
following their individual gradient and
what's important here is that the
gradient they're going to be following
is just part of the actual gradient so
it's only
so the actual gradient of the loss has
this extra
term due to the decision dependence in
the distribution
and so instead what they're going to do
is uh just use the thing that we can we
can compute stochastically without
knowledge of d of x which is just
samples of this first term
so if we run this process we can show
that this
uh converges to the performance stable
point and the way that we're going to do
that
is first get a one-step contraction
so this is standard in optimization and
strong monotonicity enables us to sort
of prove these results
as a fairly natural generalization of
what we know in standard optimization
and so the only thing we need here in
addition to the assumptions that i
listed before
is we need some variance bound on our
gradient estimate so this g here these
sort of stochastic samples of the this
explicit partial gradient um these guys
are going to be our at the estimates
that for the individual gradients that
each player is going to follow
and so we need some variance bound on
those estimators
and we need
the expected uh
expected value of this guy g to be l
lipschitz and then with that condition
in the regime where rho is less than one
so this gives us existence if we choose
our step size appropriately then we can
get this one step contraction
once you have a one step contraction you
can do all kinds of different algorithms
to converge to
a
to the the
equilibrium of this process which is the
formally stable point one such algorithm
is to just decay the step size
uh in half over a bunch of epochs so the
way it works we start we're going to
divide our time up into capital k e box
which i'll define here in a second
and we're going to
run
this repeated
stochastic gradient play
algorithm for capital t naught steps so
this is proportional inversely
proportional to eta naught here
and then in the next iteration we're
going to take where we ended up as the
initial condition for the next epoch and
we're going to cut the step size in half
again inversely proportional to a to 1
here and if we keep repeating this
process
we can show that after capital k epochs
which depends on our target accuracy
epsilon here so we'll set that at the
beginning
uh after capital k epochs
we'll be within a epsilon neighborhood
of uh the
um
performatively stable point
so we can get the following result that
says what is the total number of
iterations that we'll take so the
iteration complexity so that's basically
the sum of these tk's uh for k equals
one k equals zero up to capital k
so that will have iteration complexity
as given here so essentially exactly
what you would expect for any stochastic
gradient method you have the same kind
of iteration complexity
but what is the star here i mean the
performantly stable point the
performance stable equilibrium
what is the initial equilibrium
the equilibrium that we were setting
yeah sounds a little bit magic because
we forget at all the
second time implicit trading
[Music]
i will talk about how we can use the
implicit gradient but this is saying
which point do we converge to if we
ignore the
implicit gradient so the definition of
proportionally stable equilibrium has to
do with ignoring that component
so it's not a it's called an equilibrium
but it's not in any game theoretic sense
it's in the sense of that repeated nash
process
okay
so now if players are no longer naive so
they're going to now care about that
explicit
or the implicit partial gradient so we
want to compute nash equilibrium now so
the difference between the proformally
stable point and the nash equilibrium is
shown here so
we actually now
optimize over the decision dependence in
this distribution whereas before we were
not doing that right we were just
putting xs into the that distribution
so this is our definition of nash it's
pretty uh should be fairly standard
because we're looking at
the decision where in our optimization
problem
does x i show up in all places
okay so again we're going to ask same
questions
when do equilibrium exist when do these
particular type of equilibrium exist
and then what algorithms are going to
converge to them
okay so we'll again use this sort of
classical or this strong monotonicity
property um and the reason is that we
know from rosen's classical paper from
65 that if
you have a strongly monotone game
then you get
existence and uniqueness of
the equilibrium so the nash equilibrium
so again i just to remind the definition
of strong monotonicity
and so how we're going to
use this to get existence
for this decision dependent game is as
follows so first we already have the
assumption that the game induced by any
y
is alpha strongly monotone and so that
relates to the strong monotonicity of
this explicit component of the
uh
gradient to the loss function so in
particular if i just write out what it
means to be alpha strongly monotone for
this game
it's literally that this mapping g
subscript y x
which has all of these uh for each eye
it has all of these components here
that mapping
needs to be strongly monotone uh in x
so for fixed y this guy needs to be
strongly monotone and x that was the
assumption we already made
so now we need some assumption on this
uh
second piece
to ensure that we have strong
monotonicity of the
overall k
and so uh to get that we're gonna do
something uh similar to what we did with
this first piece so first of all we're
gonna define this hxy vector
sorry i should have i swapped the role
of x and y
here so y is the
um so in this operator so y is the
explicit dependence in the loss function
on uh the actions of the player so again
y is a joint action profile
and the subscript x is the dependence in
the data distribution here so down here
we have y and then x in the data
distribution
and so what we can show is that in the
regime where row is less than a half
same row from before
as long as this mapping here so from x
to h subscript x y if that guy is
monotone it doesn't need to be strongly
monotone or strictly mono or so yeah it
doesn't need to be strongly monotone
just monotone
for any fixed y
then uh the game will be strongly
monotone and the parameter will be 1
minus 2 rho
alpha that's why we need
row to be less than a half for this
game to have a
nash equilibrium and it be
unique i'll just give an example um if
people are interested i can show how we
actually make this argument but in lieu
of that um
what i'll do is just give an example of
how this happens again in this example
of uh
uber versus lyft
um so let's say that these ride share
companies now they want to
um
maximize their revenue so this first
term is the
so we're doing loss minimization here so
negative the revenue is going to be
their loss
the first term is the revenue here and
then we have some
regularization on the vector x here x is
going to be the price z is going to be
the demand
and if we have this setup where z is
follows a location scale distribution
so
here really we're just talking about the
location parameter being affected by x
so we have some base distribution
defined by this random variable zeta
here
and then we have the price elasticities
due to competition
sorry due to competition and due to your
own sort of performative effects if you
will then if we compute these maps h
for each player h x y
it's pretty simple we just take the
gradient of l with respect to z and then
the gradient of z with respect to x i
which is where the ai here comes up
then this thing is just a constant
mapping so that doesn't even depend on x
at all so it's trivially monotone
so there's lots of examples like this we
have several other ones in the paper but
um you know
this is sort of a simple trivial one
that shows when we satisfy the
assumptions that lead to
existence and uniqueness of the
equilibrium
all right so we have existence and
uniqueness and now we want to talk about
algorithms
that makes
well-defined definition of h do you have
any characterization of what should
happen to the distribution
somehow how i can understand yeah so in
the separable case uh when your law your
loss doesn't explicitly
depend on the competition so if we just
have expected value of the loss uh for l
i x i z i then this literally boils down
to what's called a mixture dominance
condition on the the distribution so it
satisfies some convexity com condition
in itself
and that's also known in the single
player case
all right so we're going to talk about
two algorithms
so the first is kind of natural if you
don't have access to this data
distribution
but you still want to account for that
explicit partial gradient then what
we'll do is we'll look at derivative
free methods and i'll show when those
converge
uh in this case where we have a monotone
strongly monotone game and then we'll
look at this
setup that's motivated by
adaptive control
so in particular players will have a
parametric description of this
decision-dependent distribution and
adaptively estimate that while
simultaneously optimizing their
individual losses
okay so for the bandit feedback setting
i'll just talk about this in the context
of general strongly monotone games
because we actually
have improved the rate for those
the known rate for those games
so the setup is as follows we have a
strongly monotone game defined on our
you know convex compact joint action
space here and players are going to do
this single point blacksmith style uh
gradient estimate so what that means is
they perturb
every player perturbs their action
using some query radius and a unit
vector sampled from uh the or sorry
a vector sample from the units here
so if they do this um then it turns out
okay so in the decision dependent
setting this is what this looks like so
we have our loss function again with
these queries and then our distribution
is also going to be perturbed
so
um
what it turns out is that if you take
the expected value of this guy it's an
unbiased estimator of what's called the
smooth cost and then we can simply bound
or make some arguments about the
relationship between the smooth cost and
the original cost of the game
and that leads to the results that we
have and i'll show that in a second um
so once players have this gradient
estimate they're just going to do
projected
individual gradient descent
okay so the known convergence rates from
2018
were uh you know had square dependence
on the dimension
and then uh epsilon minus three in terms
of the target accuracy
uh these were shown by bravo at all they
conjectured that the rate should be
what we have down here so this is um
also the uh optimal rate in the single
player setting
for the single point gradient estimates
that i've shown that if you have
multiple point gradient estimates you
can do a little better than this you can
get a square root a d factor
instead of a d square of dependence
so we're able to get uh this uh
rate for general strongly monotone games
so then that of course applies to the
decision dependent setting that i was
just showing so i also want to mention
that
at the same time that we got uh we
proved this rate um
t and e and
someone's collaborators so tmu's a grad
student here
uh got a similar uh got the same rate
using a different method so it's kind of
cool but you know we're able to show
this for this particular 1.3 and
estimate they have a similar one-point
gradient estimate but they use a
concordant barrier function
to get the the same kind of rate
okay so how do we do this um we actually
have a really i mean the proof is really
short um
so the intuition is as follows we're
just going to view everything in terms
of structural stability of uh perturbed
gains
so we define our nash equilibrium on the
original game was going to be this x
star here
so the original game in terms of f on x
oh one important point that i didn't
mention here is that players when
they're doing their projection they're
doing it on a retracted set
so this is their crew radius that shows
up here
and you want to retract that set to
ensure that when you are evaluating your
loss function
um
you're doing it inside the constraint
set x so that's important
so
[Music]
each player computes
their own strategies
so what is this uh delta something added
to the second floor
like so the other player is also doing
that so this is the
this is what they're querying the
environment with as well so all of them
perturb their actions
send it to some oracle oracle sends back
all of the losses
yes so
yeah so we're gonna um yeah
the
the rail conversion
in terms of the
play
actions
uh
in terms of x t so this is not like x t
plus delta if that's the difference yeah
that's what i'm asking because actually
i mean
so let's say they run it for capital t
iterations then the last iterate that's
produced by the algorithm
um that would be the national worker or
be satisfy this guarantee
but
i'm confused the players are playing the
data or the extinct would you say
they're querying the environment with x
plus delta v
but there is about xp
i mean they're choosing those deltas and
b right so the ultimate goal is to find
the snatch equipment they stop after
some time then they'll have this we'll
have this guaranteed
the the question is that
the difference between texting
but don't have obviously
so uh
the question is whether the actually
playing strategies
is different by delta from the
sequence from which we're providing the
rate
if the rate is still
squared
i suspect that's probably pretty easy to
handle because um the way we do this
is uh let me just show you
so we end up just splitting up the x t x
star here into
these different terms
and the second term which i'll describe
what it is in a minute is just delta
times something and then we choose delta
to make sure that small so if we also
had a delta times you know v
so if you choose to be something in
order to cover some properties then it
doesn't seem that you can choose delta
in order to cover also
uh so if you want to get the the rate
for xt plus delta v
i think we can get exactly the same rate
for that result
and then we can also get the rate if we
just did
but not both simultaneously for the same
delta maybe if you did some min
or whatever choose delta to be the best
best of both cases that would work
okay so
yeah i don't know how much time
so yeah the way we do this is that um
it's kind of
a
trivial thing here defining the original
nash equilibrium the national library
for the original game on the set that we
care about then we define nash of these
auxiliary games so one
is of the
smooth losses on the retracted set
and then one is of
the original losses also on the
retracted set
so then using a triangle inequality we
can bound this first term because
you know there's some we can exploit
some structural stability property of
the viewing this guy is just a
perturbation of the original game
and we can bound that in terms of delta
the same thing
it turns out that you can relate the
normal cone
for these different sets and leverage
that property to just bound that second
term
i can show details if people are
interested but otherwise uh we'll kind
of move on
okay so we want to talk about now the
second set of algorithms let me just
check the time
okay like a few minutes
um so the second algorithm class is
going to try to exploit some knowledge
of the underlying distribution
so again we're going to
appeal to this location scale family
where
it is the location parameter that is
dependent on
x and so
here
players are going to adaptively form
estimates of
these matrices a that affect their
decision dependent distribution
uh and then uh the way that they do that
is uh injecting noise um such that the
online least squares problem uh actually
converges so they're gonna form an
online lease squares problem to estimate
those h
and so the algorithm looks a lot like
adaptive control
because that's basically what it is
except it's in a multiplayer case
so players
inject noise they query the environment
and so they're here they're querying the
environment uh twice so one at xt and
then one at xt plus this injected noise
if we don't want to deal with
multiple queries i mean this is only to
deal with like not assuming that the
base distribution
zeta is zero mean so it's just a
technical thing here
otherwise they could re-center
everything at each step as well
and so they do an estimation this is
just one step of
least squares here online least squares
and then they simultaneously do a
gradient step
using the estimated implicit partial
gradient in addition to the
original original stochastic
explicit partial gradient
so this actually converges at uh the
same rate as if they already knew those
matrices a
um and so
uh i'll just kind of show and this is a
synthetic simulation example showing
that the rate matches uh the stochastic
gradient play and then the derivative
free method here uh converges but does
does so uh at a worse rate
so the key idea here
is
similar to what we see in
adaptive control is that we want our
estimation problem to be persistently
exciting so we inject noise
appropriately to achieve that so i think
an interesting open direction is to
think about
estimating that implicit partial
gradient using techniques from adaptive
control so for example it's known there
that certain classes of functions
are already
have these persistence of excitation
properties like radial basis functions
for example and so an interesting
direction is to try to have more general
descriptions of our decision dependent
distribution that already have the nice
properties that ensure that we can
estimate them
okay so i'm going to conclude here in
the next few minutes by talking about
this ride share
kind of toy problem but using real data
so this is what people call
semi-synthetic simulations
um and the the goal will be to just kind
of expose some interesting things that
we observed empirically that i think
lead to open questions
okay so each player again is going to
try to maximize their revenue or
minimize the negative of their
revenue here
with some regularization term
we have some base demand
there's going to be
different effects uh
you'll have your own performative
effects
uh and so there's this is just
representing it will represent some
negative price elasticity uh and then
we'll have some positive price
elasticity do the competition so your
competition raises their price it's
going to increase your the demand for
for your service
so there's a nice little data set
on uh kaggle here for from
boston that has both uber and lyft data
in it so it's really hard actually to
find these nice data sets where people
have actually taken multiple actions and
then users have responded much less have
this competition
so um this data set's not huge but it
serves its purpose for what we're doing
so what we do is we take the data which
has um rides at different prices with
different surge mechanisms from
different locations for each of the the
different services in boston over a 14
day period
and so we bend the rides into five
dollar increments so zero to five five
to 10 and so on and then for each bin we
estimate a we have an empirical
distribution so we just sample from that
bin and then we're going to treat the
decision as the surge price for each bin
so how much do you add extra on top of
the cost
and then we estimate these performative
effects
from the data
um okay so the first is just a simple
little observation that if players
ignore
the competition so ignore the
performative effects due to competition
if we um compute the resulting
equilibrium of the learning process that
arises from that uh them being myopic in
the case where
either lips myopic individually uber's
myopic individually or both are myopic
they perform better they have more
revenue under the nash equilibrium so
this is suggesting that modeling
performative effects is a positive thing
for for players to be doing
the second thing i think is even maybe
more interesting and suggestive of
directions to go
so if we compute
a sort of price of anarchy so we have a
unique equilibrium here
for both the case of performantly stable
equilibrium as well as the nash
equilibrium and we can compare to the
social
uh so i'm here i'm talking about
the negative of the losses negative of
the sum of the losses for the players
and then um
the
the social welfare being the negative at
the sum of the losses for the players at
the socially optimal equilibrium so
we're going to just use this as a metric
so if you look at the 5 to 10 price bin
so the price of anarchy
for the performantly stable point is
pretty close to the nash equilibrium
so we might care about this because this
performance stable point requires less
assumptions to compute
it's pretty easy to implement naively
without having any information about the
decision dependent distribution
and so it's interesting that
in terms of social welfare these are
almost equivalent so one thing though to
point out is that if you look at the
market share
in terms of revenue
for the nash equilibrium it's more
reflective of what the social optimum is
whereas
the formerly stable point has this
uh you know some of the market share
gets shifted over to uh the
uh from lyft to uber
so while uh they have roughly the same
um
price of anarchy uh
at the same time the market share
distribution is wildly different
so that's an interesting observation
and then in the 15 price bin we kind of
have um
a different sort of story so the
performance
stable point is much
the price of anarchy is much uh lower so
worse than the nash equilibrium
and
you don't have quite as big of a
disparity between uh there's still some
in terms of market share but not quite
as big
so this suggests that um
an interesting direction would be to
better have a better analytical
characterization of quantities like this
uh and then also to think about okay
well if you know points like the
performance stable
equilibrium are better in terms of
social welfare or vice versa how do you
incentivize players to go after those
versus the other equilibrium concept
yeah
i'm not really aware of data science so
how did you run these experiments are
data
i'm trying to understand
how did you learn
oh so the data actually has the price of
the rights
uh and they are open you mean yeah okay
it's not so cable is one of those
competition sites for data science and
they post a lot of free data so if
you're interested in getting data that's
a good place to go
yeah yeah so they put it up there so
yeah otherwise this is really hard to
get data like this type so yeah okay
how did you compute externalities of one
to the other
the a matrices in your notation
how do you estimate those from the data
they
interesting uh
yeah so
honey do you remember how
you guys did this
how we estimated that a matrix is from
the data
you and evan came up with some scheme
for that
i feel like we use
some kind of heuristic about how
the demand should be affected
by changes in price and it was
definitely like very add-on kind of
synthetic in a way but
it definitely should align with
if the other person's price decreases
then your demand should go down and if
the other person's price
increases then your demand should go up
and then the amount the change would
happen was
like if the other person's price
increases by like for certain percent
say like 10 percent
maybe your demand could good one by like
five percent or something
if you just use like some heuristic
numbers and put them in there then you
can just
backtrack
something
so but the result was a symmetry between
lyft and uber right so uh there's more
rides for
uh i think lift in the data set than
uber so yeah so the cause of this
assembly was i mean in this in this
formulation the only assembly i see
would be
i don't know the zi's are different for
me
yeah
yeah so there's so use the same matrices
but different distribution for they are
uh they have different matrices for each
player so there's different a matrices
for each player all right so you did
estimate the data yeah in some way so
there's a heuristic for like
uh how like what
the relative proportion
um
i guess it should go up or down based on
the increase uh that one player makes
versus the other but then
you actually use the the the data to get
the actual values right exactly
i think you describe it in a paper file
sorry
is that your using adaptive control rule
is that what you're using the adapter
control uh
gradient
like the adaptive control update
or uh
sorry i don't think i understand what
you're asking so in the adaptive control
algorithm players are estimating these
things
so we in terms of estimating those for
the simulation that's a different thing
so we estimated those from data using a
heuristic and then we simulate the
environment using those estimated
matrices and players are estimating this
so there's that's what these things are
like semi-synthetic simulations in the
sense that like you're simulating the
performative effects based on some
estimation of those parameters from the
data but then players are still trying
to learn those things
because i'm conscious too about that
initially i thought that we're trying to
estimate alpha with
ely square approach the players are
but there's a difference between like
the oracle simulator that's running
underneath
so we have a simulation environment that
simulates the environment
to set that simulation up we estimated
the a we as the
with us
as the scientists estimated those
matrices from the data and then we run a
simulation on top of those where the
players lift and uber are estimating the
effects of a
so there's like different kinds of
estimation there
it couldn't be the case that we have a
single agent
if i say that i am the scientist in a
single agent environment and i'm trying
to estimate
no no no that's just to set up the
simulator so just like you set up a
robotic simulator or something like that
you need to pick parameters to run the
simulator
so we pick parameters to run the
simulator and the way we do that it's
based on heuristics and the data
then we run
the
you know lift an uber on top of that so
when
that's basically to create the oracle
right so when with an uber sample from
the loss function oracle that's based on
our simulator that we set up using the
data so you're trying to set up the
ground truth actually in the first step
yeah this is again why it's called
semi-synthetic because it's not real
yes
the elaborate is it's a broader
challenge it seems like
semi-synthetic and that
you're using data to analyze a decision
problem where the data depends on
decisions yeah so yeah there's a chicken
and egg i completely agree um and so
you know moving forward we're doing some
actual experiments with you know
decision makers individual humans for
example where we can actually deal with
that problem another way to deal with it
is to break the data up so you're only
estimating from some chunk of the data
and then you're simulating on the rest
like we do in machine learning but yeah
i completely agree this is like a this
is a huge problem in this space yeah
it is in general in control too right so
uh when you talk about social welfare
you're talking about like the
revenue the circle
like the revenue maximizing strategies
for legitimate right we're not talking
about good consumers or the
yeah yeah just yeah yeah yeah no no
model of those uh individuals yeah yeah
yeah
okay
um
yeah that was basically it but i just
wanted to
end with
one thing here
so some of the things some of the open
questions that i think here are there's
a huge humble open question beyond this
semi-synthetic thing which is also a big
issue in this area but you know so we
talked a lot about you know at the
beginning i motivated the strategic
behavior but we really were abstracting
out that strategic behavior in terms of
an ensemble or population level
distribution
and so really there's some interesting
questions related to building in
behavioral models or more specific
human decision making models that
capture
you know
things like comparing to reference
points or risk aversion etc in addition
we talked about one population of users
it's also of interest to think about
multiple populations of users and how
the market share splits up amongst those
users and related to that is
incorporating sort of in
economic constraints like individual
rationality for those users
and so for example users might decide if
they're comparing to an outside option
to just not participate and so then
you'll have this sort of attrition in
the underlying population
and so
that's an interesting effect to sort of
account for and then finally in machine
learning we don't just care about
optimization performance we care about
things like generalization error and so
that's you know so there's some open
questions around
actually defining what that means when
you have decision dependence so there's
a little bit of work on reinforcement
learning that tries to do this
but i think that's a an interesting
direction to go as well as more formally
characterizing those efficiency bounds
like things like uh price of anarchy etc
so i'll just conclude with that and if
anybody's interested in working on these
things i'm happy to collaborate with
anyone so you can certainly reach out so
that's that's it
um your setup feels a lot like a
multi-population minikill game
uh
and like where for instance in that
example you gave
your like the demands felt a lot like
the state space and you have like in
what you're solving for for really feels
like a mean field
uh in nash equilibrium like do are you
aware of any connections like similar
results hold also in that literature
yeah so um
it's not
quite the setup i have isn't quite a
mean-filled game uh in the sense that um
you're
like the decision maker is just still
optimizing its loss but it just has some
decision dependence in its distribution
so it's more like a degenerate
reinforcement learning problem where
there's a static underlying distribution
however an actual next step would be to
think about the population so that
decision dependent distribution actually
changing in time following some mean
field dynamics so let's say users in
that population are actually competing
with each other and they have
homogeneous preferences etc and maybe
they have their own loss and so then you
would have this evolution of d of x
dependent on time as they're learning um
in some mean field sense so you're
saying that's like the difference
between i guess an exogenous versus an
endogenous change in the model or
both are talking about endogenous
changes in the model
exogenous would be like some external
uh you know additional external input
okay
endogenous from the perspective of a
decision dependent learner exogenous
from the perspective of the
population okay
because i don't really see the
difference i'm sorry so there's two
different decision makers right in that
sense so you can think about the
decision dependent learner who's
optimizing the loss given this decision
dependent distribution and then you also
think about that decision dependent
distribution as a population of agents
optimizing some loss function in a mean
field sentence which we haven't done
here but that's an interesting direction
so there
x would be an exogenous input to that
population but from the point of view of
the decision dependent learner it's an
endogenous effect on the population
any any other questions
yeah uh thanks for the time very
interesting so just uh curious about the
made some several assumptions about the
convexity of games
uh how plausible are they are
going to be in the reality for example
your experiments are just like very
satisfied or
just i think so for the simple model
that we set up with this revenue
maximization and then also for like you
know people look at strategic
classification where you have some
logistic loss with a regularization term
to improve generalization performance
those all satisfy
these conditions but it is a fair
assumption that you could have you know
if you had some more complicated like
neural network kind of architecture or
something that's part of those you know
loss minimization then that totally
would be non-complex so
yeah it's definitely an interesting
direction to try to relax those
just following up on that question do
you know if it's possible to remove the
regularizer and get like something that
works under monotonicity but not strong
one ethnicity
that yeah that's a natural next step i
haven't thought about it but there's
tons of papers looking at you know
optimization in games for when you relax
that so i think yeah completely would be
worth looking at in this context
so i want to go back to the question of
jeff
what i'm trying to understand a little
bit is the applicability of the models
because we want to see what the players
will play
from some data but
at the end of the day how the data
creates this alpha if
i mean
would you like to make a comment about
that because i'm trying to understand
i think the only real way to test those
kinds of things is to have actual
experiments uh you know working with
companies or setting up experiments
yourself where you actually have like
say human decision makers or something
like that that are reacting um to your
decision
maybe you know for example the previous
talk was looking at you know you have
kind of estimated ensemble behavior in
these game theoretic contexts in an
experimental way so perhaps you know
engaging with people like that who are
you know are already doing these kinds
of experiments that i mean you have to i
think that's the ultimate answer to the
question right you need to do real
experiments
because these semi-synthetic things you
know they they're wrought with problems
of this sort yeah and i'm not going to
defend that in any way because i i
i think
[Music]
uh any other any other
questions
i have a question actually
first of all thank you for your talk
very very exciting
so you know i'm like the ceo for
maybe
uber so
how do i use this paper like how do i
make more money
like uh is there any
yeah if it's true that you should model
performative effects then you should be
thinking about how your competitor is
making decisions too uh and i'm sure
they are uh you know i'm sure uber is
already trying to think about that kind
of thing
i wouldn't be surprised if they're not
tracking their drivers and seeing like
when they're on other apps and stuff
like that so
yeah
you know it's some of these things are
sort of simple
stylized models and they're making much
more complicated decisions but i think
if the underlying principle is true that
you should be modeling the effects of
your
your competitor then um that's just a
suggestion for them to do something
but does it also create like a level of
like gate rationality or like my
like i have to take into account my
opponent
like tries to like model my behavior who
well i'm also like trying to model their
behavior so is that
i think that's also interesting to to
think about if you have conjectures like
let's say that it's not true that you
know they they have these location scale
distribution but you model it as that
and so then you have a conjecture
essentially about what that behavior is
so you try to estimate that conjecture
and maybe the other guy's doing the same
so you could certainly have this nested
uh kind of behavior and actually my
student ben is working on this in the
context of human machine interaction so
there is something called a consistent
conjectural variations equilibrium which
actually predates nash
that
has this kind of natural nested
you know conjecture and estimation
concept and so that's one of the things
we're actually working on
in terms of human machine interaction
not in this context but it would
certainly apply here too
great
any any last question
okay if not let's thank you again
[Applause]
interactive talk it's fun when you have
people